yeah hello and welcome to this video
round six no again and making this
mistake it's Game six of the World
Championship match between change the
Sega kayaking from Russia and Norwegian
world champion magnus cows yeah we had
very um epic struggle Game three four
five and as you already see from the
video length of this round six that
wasn't as epic as the games before quite
understand why you cannot play like 100
moves every day let's see what happened
in this game so the Challenger plays
efore again I'm surprised that he keeps
doing that I mean unless he has a
strategy of like blood playing yeah I
mean okay playing for draw with writer
that's a little bit harsh but um yeah I
don't know we'll see what happens in
this game we have a row again and we
repeat the opening line of Game four so
Carlton is some basically signaling his
intention to play a marshal we don't
actually know if he would play it I mean
he has played this perform but didn't
pair all that well with it to be honest
it is perfectly possible that he would
just go d6 and play a mainline brea but
possibly the Bram it's what you usually
does if he goes for the absolute main
dining and certainly possible we don't
know because kayaking place 8 free so in
a way maybe this is a big Bluff and God
it's not actually intending to play the
marshal so we have again this line
Commission p7 d3 and here in game 4
cards ahead play to d6 I'm leading to a
typical closed position yeah we had a 3
Queen d7 if i remember correctly and we
had this maneuvering game where
yeah kayaking went wrong and later
played that we had Bishop takes e4
capture it was that game that you
probably will remember if you've seen
the the whole match so this time carlton
goes d5 not d6 this is the most
principled move them I'm going for pawn
sacrifice anyway now White has prevented
the marshal but black sacrifices anyway
so why is that a sacrifice takes takes
takes white can rep you five and this is
what happened in the game so the world
champion has given up a big sent upon
yeah what is blacks point of the
sacrifice the actually here has to quite
decent option and at least from what I
learned when looking now to prepare for
this video it is theoretically not quite
established if black should play nine to
deform or capture only five those two
moves come into consideration after the
capture black is some I usually
continuing with moves like queen to d6
it's a situation where blacks
compensation is consisting quite often
this is coming next by the way it's
consisting in space advantage it's got
more space in the center and on the
queenside and of course the development
yeah we see that white has a couple of
pieces still on their starting squares
well black is after a future rook move
or group d aid and route eh it's not
correct here what's best in any case
black retains very good compensation
here the alternative here is to play
what Carson did actually played Nyjah
deform so basically avoiding the trade
in the middle and looking at this Bishop
this is a little bit of a different
approach here black um also has some
central advantages but he gets the
bishop pay on top you had those night
moves in
roll they basically trade-off
development for long-term asset the
bishop pair so here after 93 this is not
the only move but it is the most
frequently played mode carden plate 92
before making some pressure and those
nights are quite annoying push up f form
now he took it and played c5 so we are
on move 14 here and this is going to my
database it isn't normal tip I don't
have those correspondence databases and
then fancy stuff so it might be a no
move in some in some circles both them
sides have played rather quickly yeah
kayaking not spending any time the
questioner ever has to be asked what
exactly is what is what exactly what is
intentionally in this position it is
actually a very comfortable position for
black yeah with the bishop pal the
compensation is very nice and whether
you should never underestimate us blacks
potential to if we just look at having
enough for the pawn legs potential to
sometimes just trade down to opposite
colored bishops and if this Bishop is
going to trade it for a night and this
is very easy to accomplish most likely
because the night system they cannot run
away from the bishop and they don't want
to then this is a quite often a drawing
a weapon there just to go to the
opposite kind of bishops this is not
something that black has to do correctly
just an option that helps them to have
enough compensation here so on what
would you expect here that kayak it has
some idea up his sleeve but he actually
played after like 10 minutes 94 and this
is extremely unimpressive the question
is however can you do something else I
mean actually you shouldn't think you
should help us prep going and there was
huge speculation before the match what
was kind of fantastic preparation you
must
being supported by the whole yeah
Russian let's say she has a lead but
somehow we don't get this get this
feeling during the match that there is
something well it was completely I don't
know it doesn't hit it's in some way
because Carlton is winning every opening
duel I mean every single one and even
every game he was the one to get a new
move in or get the initiative in a way
of psychologically because kayaking is
the first to take a long thing so this
is really surprising and was certainly
not to be an anticipated um one thing
that basically everybody said is that
kayak ins main chance could be to catch
Magnus in the opening and no way yeah
there's absolutely nothing happening in
that regard so 94 what did Magnus play
it's not exactly difficult young he
played f6 the night is a tech has only
the square chair go Geoffrey now f5 yeah
attacking the second night and yeah with
the next move kayaking is basically
saying okay that's my control yeah I
mean at least there is am forcing almost
forcing drawing a path after the move he
could have played this move to avoid
what happened in the game mean black is
perfectly fine he can just play normal
moves let's say we piayed I mean note
that he has good central control the
night is very strong white can never
easily place III as g3 is hanging so the
night on before is constantly
pressurizing the sea to pawn and cannot
be expelled easily and black is very
comfortable so this is a position where
yeah there's little incentive to go for
it unless um I mean this is a possible
of course that was this game ok I can
team said ok we will be very safe and
let's just make a draw possible possible
um but just from pure chess perspective
this promises very very little yeah he
went to g5
I said end here cards now has an easy
task oks to hack the snide knight takes
Bishop cakes it's very unimpressive due
to Bishop takes a three yeah and
blankets very fine so the night had to
capture and it first it looks a little
bit little bit dangerous here but in
fact black action encourages this this
action yeah the thing is that Knight f3
just to show the alternatives is no good
due to the capture again yeah the issue
is really always that the queen is tied
to the defense of that poor now we have
a big Fork em so G takes and then
tweenage for this is no good like it's
just better here so what ok I can head
to go Queenie 6 there's just no other
move and now queen d5 simultaneously
threatening mate having a look at the
night yum f3 only move rook e8 yeah and
now let's have a look at this what is
why it's supposed to play now the night
is hanging on only six not that Carlton
has spent like a couple of minutes so he
is very likely stood in his preparation
as it should be yeah we just don't move
20 and heavily analyzed line so ok the
night is attacked should go here clap
black has this check available and it's
not in any way of puzzled here all upset
about this proceeding it actually should
end in a draw and I'm some funny so
funny line here like you put this on the
board and like is getting his revenge
here in a way yeah yeah this is a funny
line reading leading to a perpetual yeah
black is a piece up but white is
threatening all kinds of draws him and
black cannot avoid that funny enough um
yeah so in the game and that one other
that
was not played ki can plate rupee 5
attacking the Queen which went back to
the stakes and it looks a little bit
weird yeah bill bit shaky in a way but
there is very little that that one can
do here and with kya kiya noisy place
2222 c3 after that is basically dead um
alternatively he could have played look
to e to continuing the game but after
Queen D 797 rookie to Queen into and
rook c8 it also seems that black is
perfectly fine something like Ruby one
now for example can be answered by the
check clap Queen here 92 yeah it's a
longish line but ultimately also not
leading to all that much here after
night c2 What's My Line their chicks
chicks and you g7 widest actor fear of
course but something like that is check
what easily becoming something totally
dead like this no way you're probably um
gavels will see a draw even if the side
porn down is just a much bigger play
because you will get an impregnable
fortress anyway yeah so this was a
little bit more interesting in a way and
c3 was played and yeah here I'm black
now basically is forced to take on e6
for this mansion to completely sterile
position there is also no alternative
here black goes back and then he
actually has to play a pawn down for
nothing nothing tangible so he had to do
this and I mean I mean black carbon is
ok with the draw in the situation taken
taken the night now and here if we do
account it six points each um
they're only a little idea then why
might have here is like DD Form we
should be five and that vaguely trying
to do something on g7 but this is
although almost always going to be
defended we have opposite colored Bishop
sandwich with Queens on the board and a
little bit fire little bit of firepower
can actually be dynamic and attacking
attacking weapon but here we have so
much traded already that it is hard to
imagine that white would get anything
here like Bishop before to d4 Bishop b5
route to c7 those kind of things could
work but it's just a matter of time I
mean Black is just quick and nothing and
we get this hat exchanged as well yeah
countenance advancing on the Queen
silent there we have some traits
actually and here after Bishop e6 drama
Creed um yeah it is good that they agree
tea and didn't have to play on
pointlessly this is really making no
sense and yeah here black just draws
with very easy play you just put the
Queen somewhere here on a light square
and just stay put nothing happens yeah I
mean the only thing imaginable is like
Bishop here and black overlooks are made
on 27 and that's not happening in a
world championship match so um this is
probably the least interesting game of
the whole bunch of the whole match and
it is in some way interesting in that
kayak and he is not objecting to to make
a basically non-game draw and I also
wonder does he really feel like playing
for joy with white is the right strategy
because it's something that cannot be
the preparation I mean what kind of
preparation is that if you mean does
this position is so easy to play I mean
you don't need to be Magnus card in here
with black to make a draw from here so
it's really easy
so a little bit mysterious a little bit
mysterious um on the other end okay as I
said it might be the strategy here in
context of the long games before and so
on you never know you don't don't have
all the information available yeah I
mean there are things that we simply
unaware of him if you I can current
example from my own practice I had a
game a couple of days ago where I called
her some stomach bug the night before
the game and I can assure you I did not
want to play chess whatsoever I mean
really this was the the right time for a
quick draw it which didn't happen ahead
played anyway but in the context of an
important match if you really feel
completely rotten for some reason it is
not a bad idea to play a non game and
just basically delay the fight so we
never know the context there however in
terms of preparation Carson looks very
well prepared is in absolutely no
trouble whatsoever on the opening and
yeah we can look forward to the next
game which will be on sunday the
twentieth so that will be again a kayak
in the white game and I mean okay it's
not a big surprise in my cellar but i'm
pretty sure you watch her harder than
this one ok guys thanks for watching